[Music]
you collaborated for the film you
collaborated with
formerly snoop dogg now he's known as
snoop lion lion yeah i'm gonna go with
snoop dogg uh
he collaborated with you on a song that
you wrote for the movie can you tell us
about that song uh yes the song is
called take yo panties off
and uh it's a song i wrote
um
you know i do comedy and uh and i played
play keyboard and sing
and uh one day i was in
fort worth texas
and there was this waitress and uh
she just kind of was
working right in front of me and she had
these legs that wasn't stopping
take your panties off it just came out
my mouth just
and that was like about eight years ago
that's how all the best songs are
written about it
so um
snoop and i uh got together and we did
kind of a remix to it in this on the
soundtrack you did a song called take
your pennies off with snoop dogg with
snoop dogg and he he is a very wise dude
he's he's he's uh he's a leader and he
came in
he came in and he rocked the leader of
man
it really he's got a lot of knowledge
and he gets in that studio he don't mess
around so uh i had to learn a couple
things okay wow uh the movie this
movie's about he's like a leader in
panty taking off
[Laughter]
oh yeah that isn't even a handkerchief
that's a that is a hand towel you just
pulled out you just pulled out a a
that's a giant hand towel i always keep
a towel with me because i'm either
sweating or about to sweat
that's the real you'll see you gotta get
that side
you see it in the movie too it's uh i
keep my talent itself as monogram said
mr robinson
[Laughter]
this movie's about the end of the world
okay i got to ask you are you one of
those people that thinks about like
do you think about what you would do do
you have like an earthquake preparedness
kit are you ready in case some stuff
goes down i know i'm going to um
i would like to be you know with my
family if that you know happens to come
about um
and you know eventually i need sex so i
hope my cousin charisse is there but the
um
what
but um
i figured i would have a lot of water
you know because you can barter for
things and i would fashion some kind of
scythe
like on my elbow right here yeah yeah
you know look oh like the cutting for
the cutting the weight like what death
carry you'd have a giant blade on your
hand yeah i would have no it would be
like from here to wrist to the elbow so
you could like punch and kind of
cut people you'd have that and a towel
ready for blotting
chill and then block
blood kill blots
that's a deadly combination